if there is one thing that connects
people around the world it's a love of
food almost no one knows that better
than atlas obscura the company behind
travel guides to fascinating places
their new book is called gastro obscura
a food adventurous guide it highlights
everything from food that is naturally
hallucinogenic to why we have giant
sloths to thank for avocados and the
reason why single men in denmark get
doused with spices on their birthdays so
we wanted to hunt down some answers in a
food tour around new york city
within its pages gastro obscura reveals
more than 500 food facts that inspired a
food journey of my own highlands pad
thai is one of the most recognized meals
on the planet but it wouldn't even exist
if it were not for a dictator in 1939
field marshal plek people sangria wanted
to promote thai culture and move people
away from consuming rice which was seen
as chinese so
he
invented
pad thai
some foods require more of a hike the
haushan tea house is on top of mount hua
one of the most sacred peaks in china to
earn this cup of tea be prepared to make
a dangerous 7 000 foot trek across a
thin ledge and then no ledge at all and
those who make it to the top say that
cup of tea is quote the most satisfying
they've ever had now this cup of tea
doesn't require a death-defying trek
[Music]
but it's still pretty delicious
if you're more of a coffee person pack
your bags for ethiopia high in the
mountains you'll find the east african
country's wild coffee forest the highly
sensitive arabica bean is at high risk
of extinction because of climate change
these are some of the last wild coffee
plants in the world but if that's not
rare enough for you how far would you
travel for threads of god it takes a
20-mile trek in italy sardinia during
the feast of san francisco to get your
hands on what may be the rarest noodle
in the world only three women from one
family know how to make this extremely
thin pasta called sufilinde many have
tried and failed to recreate these
delicately exquisite noodles for those
who want a bang in each bite taiwan is
the place to go only on moonless nights
fishermen head out into the pacific to
fire fish
that's right
they set off explosives in the water
which creates a light attracting
thousands of sardines but why go fishing
when the fish can come to you 124 miles
from the ocean is euro honduras its
first major rainfall of the spring
brings thunder
lightning and fish
the juvia depeches or rain of fish fills
the streets with the still living
creatures fresh fish for the taking to
toast our journey around the world
champagne
bet you didn't know that this used to be
considered
a performance enhancer
they even guzzled the bubbly during a
marathon at the 1908 london olympics
[Music]
i won't be doing that because we know
better and also because i'm probably
going to have another
tough assignment i know dylan thirus the
co-founder of atlas obscura and the
co-author of gastro spirit joins us now
welcome good morning
so let's talk about this atlas obscurate
and the team how did you find all these
stories because you go all over the
world yeah so so both atlas obscura and
gastro obscura work in the same way
which is we started both
as a way of telling incredible hidden
stories around the world sort of unsung
wonders and in both cases we reached out
to the community and they said tell us
about the most interesting stories near
you in this case it's all about what are
the most interesting food stories drink
stories
restaurants and so that's how it started
this has been a book four years in the
making and so people sent in stuff and
then my co-author cece and i so half the
entries come from there and then about
half come from cecily and i exploring
the world and finding things to add can
i just say something about unsung
wonders like lime cured bull testicles
thank you
big ass ants peru no thank you stuffed
camel spleen and we want to taste that
wide here let me explain let me let me
explain something so i i i don't know
where all of you are from but
i grew up in minnesota
i grew up in minnesota eating uh
lutefisk i'm scandinavian so lutefisk is
like dried fish that's then soaked in
lie there's a period where it's
poisonous it would murder you if you ate
it but they wash out the lie and then
you eat it and this is extremely popular
in the upper midwest and sort of
scandinavian areas
the point i'm saying is that basically
what is unusual what is strange is fully
relative to where you're from so like we
as americans eat an enormous amount of
cheese much of the world finds this
extremely disturbing and they smell like
cheese
and so this is kind of the point is that
it's all from where you stand what is
interesting what is unusual what is
different so gail show the book because
it's a gorgeous book yeah it's beautiful
love it i guess it's beautifully done
what you've got mark there is what
you're going to try or what you will
never try
a little bit of both yeah a lot of tabs
right there it's a lot of times but
you've got a beautiful picture of a
wedding bread a wedding bread that i
thought was one of the prettiest things
i've ever seen ukrainian wedding bread
yeah beautiful intricate stamped with
this special uh kind of a form yeah you
want you want the best looking bread
possible on your wedding of course so
dylan how do you how would you say
people should use that book because it's
kind of big for walking around on a
backpack it's not necessarily a little
travel i think there's two ways one is
as a kind of
piece of armchair travel so you can open
this book to anywhere any page and just
step into another little piece of the
world and get a sense of their food
traditions their
special flavors the things that are
really local to that place and then it's
also great to check it when you're
traveling and see maybe there's
something i want to try while i'm here
yeah it immediately became one of our
favorite books my wife and i we travel
because of food and culture so that's
perfect um what story left an imprint on
you a little bit i'll do a little
something all right and i'll try some of
that stuff
now try it once testicles you're ready
yeah yeah this is supposed to be an
appetizer so go slow yeah
they're going to take it easy
you guys love poetry
so what story left an imprint on you out
of all of these you know what's
interesting there are the ones that are
obviously surprising and then the ones
that you're familiar with but you don't
know the backstory of so in this book
actually we have an entry on pad thai
and no one is going to be we've all
eaten pad thai almost certainly but one
of the things people might not realize
is that it was kind of an invented dish
it was in the 30s the the then kind of
ruler of thailand wanted to create a new
state and said okay we need a national
dish he basically invented pad thai
because it was something he grew up
eating at home and said this is now
going to be dylan the national dish for
thailand i'm telling we have to go to
the berries okay yes we should do it
this this is all right great this is
this is the one i had in the green one
okay don't chew these there's no
okay
you just just watch out not to eat so
how are you supposed to eat them if
you're not supposed to cheese it no you
chew the berry but just watch out for
the seed in the middle oh or the scene
sour things sweet yes these are from
west africa and they're used people eat
them before drinking sour wine or eating
sour bread and they'll turn these lemons
into kind of almost like a candy tasting
treat so that's okay don't buy them
they're called miracle berries they're
called miracle berries and they're
miracle berries yeah i love them i'm not
going to try the lemon i've never had
these okay these are try a little lemon
with this
results vary
give it a lemon
i'm with you tony results berry
[Laughter]
delicious but this is a fun book results
very but the book is consistently good
dylan thank you very much dylan hey
thanks for having me gastro obscura food
adventures guide it's on sale now we'll
be right back there's the book it is
sweet at the end it is sweet